good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy Oh
my God Thursday we made it to like
almost the end of the week
congratulations everyone we are
celebrating with one of my favorite
people in the world it's Taylor's
tracker hey
oh thank you I went right from the
nostril I'm the only one allowed to sing
on the show
um that's a lie I've watched Ben sing
yeah it bothers me I watched Jackie sing
Jackie's not threatening her voice is
horrible you actually have a good voice
therefore like you're coming for my
brand
fun fact about Taylor tracker she has
like an incredible singing voice we
talked about last time I was on about my
how ashamed I was of my performance and
I told everybody they could go to my
patreon
watch it our Duets on there oh God I can
I can't ever watch my we're really good
performances we should do Duets together
you like have such a good singing voice
and I feel like for the first many years
of being your friend yes I am
I didn't know that about you secret are
you like embarrassed what it is when I
was younger I was Annie
Annie yeah cut my hair and dye it was
bonfire red Community Theater or where
in school and it was like a local
production Community
um community community theater Daddy
Warbucks was 17. I was 12. I had braces
they were raging but like I honestly
actually looked really good with red
hair and maybe I should consider but you
really committed to the role why didn't
you just put on a wig I did I kept
itching
so you shaved and dyed your hair well I
cut it here and then I tried to curl and
they were like the curls and I was like
it's I'm not cutting my hair like the
Little Dutch boy on the paint can that
is such a commitment to the theater I'm
the fact that you didn't further pursue
theater is shocking to me because that's
a level that somebody who takes like
that or seriously would do I'm a
thespian and a lesbian well that's the
truth I actually put a timer on I was
like how long is it into the episode are
we either going to talk about lesbianism
or ozempic and you made it a whole two
minutes
thank you so much are we gonna also talk
about ozone pick of course I chose a
story today that has to do with those
epic we actually have great stories
today which I'm really excited about
some thought-provoking stuff we actually
have two Britney Spears stories and
Brittany is not someone we really like
follow deeply and I understand why it's
a little it's sad yes it's chaotic yes
it's confusing and I feel like half the
things we're told are not true so it's
like what's the point in getting
invested when we're being fed lies it's
the most confusing but I feel like
you're like a big Brittany follower I am
I actually got tickets to a concert when
I was in college so I was like that's
like a real fan like High School's like
you can be fans of everybody it's true
but like to get your parents to like
give you the money like when you're
younger like to have your parents drive
you you have to be like so dedicated
that your parents are like we have to
get this [__] a ticket but also it's
like in high school it's like what the
[__] else are you doing so you're like a
concert I always think like what was I
doing in high school actually I went to
a Jewish Day School which was dual
curriculum so I was in school from eight
to five that's insane I know and now
like when I work I'm like so tired after
a few hours I'm like how did I do this
as a young a young lad yeah I don't know
oh thank you for reminding me I wanted
to ask you something please there might
be like an accusatory tone to my voice
and it's because I'm accusing you of
something one of my favorite things
about you as a person as a friend and as
a podcast host is your laugh you have
the best laugh where am I gonna get
angry at that and you also you don't
hold it like you don't withhold it from
people you laugh at people no matter how
funny how big how small the joke you la
you make me feel so funny you are so
funny and I thought that was like an
exclusive to me thing oh no I was
scrolling Tick Tock last night and I one
of your podcast Clips came up you were
podcasting with I think two other people
oh yes and the girls got to eat they
were talking yes and my God you were
cackling cackle cackle cackle cackle
like that nice raspy cackle that you
have and I was like wait a damn minute
I thought you really thought like I was
that really hysterical we need a second
psycho I do think you're that funny you
honestly you give that love to everyone
it doesn't feel special now that is not
true that sounds like I'm accusatory you
are being recusive I'm accusing abusive
yeah
listen I love to laugh I know it's one
of your best qualities I have been
accused of like fake laughing and that
is not true that's not what I was
accusing you thank you I don't think you
were fake laughing honestly I just think
you have like a low bar for comedy Now
like not that they weren't funny they
were funny I'm just saying I thought
like you're crazy laugh like was just a
me thing they were being funny like I'm
not saying this is not a slight against
your fellow co-host I also laugh at
thyself you do I am hilarious and I
crack myself up on the regular it was
just like hard for me imagine like
you're scrolling Tick Tock and something
that's so intimate like it would be like
you saw me talking about ozembic with
something with someone else it's
intimate and I just wanted to like I
wanted to come on here and ask you like
are you you know putting it on for me
are you faking with me I am not faking
laughing with you I think you okay a lot
of people make me laugh but you make me
laugh the hardest it's like one of the
rudest things anybody's ever said but I
love you for it and thank you for lying
to me
you're an amazing friend no you really
are so funny like because it's somebody
who also like has to be funny for their
job right it's quite it can be
intimidating yeah because like
especially like I mean here you make me
laugh but like also when we're not doing
our jobs the way I mean you're never not
funny like you're never not Honest by
the way you are so funny and you're my
favorite type of funny because like when
we're FaceTiming or just like having
dinner you are not trying to be funny
you are so naturally like physically and
conversationally funny that's why I'm
always telling you to get into stand up
you are really like a a very natural
funny person
this wasn't meant to be a uh but we
always do but we always compliment I was
yelling at you
let's see what I did you that's so
terrible you're so delicious I'm just
like sunshine and light and love I'm so
happy you're here for a multitude of
reasons you know how much like every
time you ask me you're like I'm sorry I
feel like it's such a big ass for you to
come into the city in the morning I
don't care get all dressed up I figured
it out in the last three weeks you have
Taylor was 12 minutes early today and we
started early we started early because
of that and the city is on fire because
of U.N general assembly and the
president is in town every street is
closed it's [__] torture I'm glad I
missed like half of it while I was in
Florida so I figured I was expecting you
to be late I myself was running a little
behind I take the subway like a plebe
you are so committed to your craft thank
you now the other reason I'm really
excited that you're here is because you
were here last week and I love
podcasting with you and I always
re-watch our episodes I actually did not
re-watch our episode
um and you can attest to this what last
week last week you were spiraling I was
really not okay as the episode
progresses I'm getting worse and worse
my stomach is like really hurting me yes
and I'm starting to like not feel great
and I've been like I've had a cold for
like the last week I don't have of covid
I took a test everybody being like you
have covaders but I didn't I took a test
[Laughter]
um but I started to like deteriorate
over the course of the hour-long podcast
that by
wrapping up so quickly you can attest I
ran out of Studio yes it's called the
fever like it was coming over me it's
the die a fever it was coming over me
yes and I just felt like I didn't do a
good job I like wasn't listening to you
and then we like we posted this picture
and everybody was like oh my God Taylor
looks amazing and I'm standing there
being like I put my makeup on and got
dressed too and I even tried like a
little extra hard because you always
come in stunting on these toes so I
tried like a little extra hard outfit
wise nobody commented a single word that
is not true because I posted it in feed
on my you did because you look so great
well hello and also average
I did I did nobody was like so many
people lies no there's so many people
about you you are both so gorgeous
listen no they were all about mine so
today I got you know what today I had
the time today I put on my Hermes belt
my orizia pants I flat ironed my
[__] hair I'm sick of you
coming in here on my show and showing me
up
even though you still look better than
me today and it's not true not in
stilettos and your Blazer I mean red
bottom [__] oh [__] I'm wearing ugly
ass Vince Camuto Vince Camuto while
she's wearing a little bit tall wait
remember when I can't walk in these FYI
they're just for sure I understand
um remember when we were at Surf Lodge
okay and my sister-in-law made a comment
about everybody wearing free people and
Claudia was like my whole outfit I'm
wearing Free People literally free
people and she's like she was like no no
it's not like a bad thing yeah she was
like why is like everybody wearing three
people like she was like ragging up for
people and then it took me a second to
realize my shirt and my matching shorts
or from free people and I'm like
actually what the [__] are you trying to
say [__]
not what the [__] you trying to say her
face
okay Ashley eat my ass [__] grab a park
and eat it
so I just wanted to clarify why I was
excited to be here and why I look
absolutely beautiful look stunning you
look like a lady who lunches you look we
are we are so beautiful I'm business
Barbie and uh lunch Barbie I'm like
Labor Day Barbie
and this whole like no wearing white
it's [__] what are your thoughts on
that they say you can't wear white after
Labor Day even though summer doesn't
typically end for about 20 days after
Labor Day like
summer is over September 21st literally
today literally today wait first of all
you are in cream AKA winter white okay
you could wear this in the dead of
winter with a boot with brown boots
that's really nice but like it's white
no it's not it's it's like Ivory I
almost wore a white white puffy shirt
and I was like it's like the end of
summer I'm gonna look ridiculous oh sh
are you saying I look ridiculous no
these are treacherous Waters today I'm
like incredibly insecure today oh my God
I don't know what it is like I thought
the oceanic would bring out like my
fiercer side yes but actually and let's
talk about this for real okay yes I'm
I'm ready for this because I'm gonna
post and fierceness like priozembic and
post let's talk about it okay so well I
I've heard you talk on the patreon about
like your journey which gave me like
even more insight to your ozmic Fifi's
than I ever even knew but like to hear
like I was crying like BRB crying
sobbing when I listen to it because the
way that you were like I was so
confident before and now like I'm
feeling insecure which like blew my mind
because like your confidence has always
been my most the most inspiring thing
about you in our friendship like I'm
like I want to be confident like Claudia
like I literally am obsessed with it
yeah thank you so but then to hear that
the Olympic made you like less confident
first of all it was confusing yeah it is
Britney Spears confusing yeah Britney
Spears confusing PSC but but then also
known as Ben saw for celebrity
but then I just like
relate to it or no no because I well I
was so deeply insecure before and I have
been so deeply insecure my whole life
yeah and now's the first time that I'm
like we're usually writing step on our
feelings and so we were having opposite
total departure I feel the most
confident I've ever felt but then uh my
producer Eva sent me a clip for a taste
of Taylor because Taylor comes out today
check it out who's on it my friend
Nicole from college so we were like
always talking about your friend Nicole
College besties yeah roommates worked it
serious together so like we go like back
into the treasures we talk about like
skinny dicks that we [__] right right
we go in but I look hideous in this
video and I was like I need to get a
facelift I need to get like um what's
that I got it kybella
I heard it doesn't work kybella I went
to the plastic surgeon to get kybella
and she was like I actually really do
not recommend it's 50 of people don't
have uh actual results and it's in
incredibly painful no she had a
procedure that she recommended which is
what I ended up getting called the
natural neck lift maybe I'll connect you
with Dr geez if you want to get it I
know a lot of people who have gotten it
I want it at the same time and then I
think a lot of people got it
at Dr geezy because I went she told me
like she she does them all the time now
and she said did you like go under no no
it's a Valium
excuse her yeah it works yeah could she
put me down by the way Olivia will tell
you the story I should ever come on the
podcast and tell the story she escorted
me to the surgery I'm dead and I'm
sitting in the in the uh doctor's office
not the the or room yet and they give me
the volume and it starts to hit and like
I'm in heaven like I was cackling me and
Olivia are having such a good time
Olivia goes to sit in the waiting room I
go all the way back to the operating
room she has an operating room in her um
office and Olivia hears blood curdling
streams no they numb you by the way so I
did not feel a thing but I was awake so
I could hear like the clanging of like
the medals I could hear like Cuts Like
You could hear cut and I was screaming
Olivia was like what is going on you
have a recollection of it yes no yeah
briefly and then she gave me more and
she was like listen this is the most I
can give you we're not in a hospital
like this like you just have to just
grin and bear it no no no like I tell
you Taylor the results okay we're worth
double the pay will you come with me
yeah of course can you like can I log in
yes by the way I'll sit in okay then
then I'm in I'm in oh wait we were we
were having a more important
conversation oh about confidence
confidence
so we're having opposite sort of
Journeys well no not as of last night
I'm like [__] now I'm insecure again
well that's the thing about being a
person on camera or just anyone who's
ever had a photo or video taken of
themselves sometimes you will see a
photo of yourself whether it be you know
candid or staged yeah and it will truly
alter the ground in which you walk on it
is a life earth-shattering moment where
you're like it's holy [__] it's is that
what I look like masochistic to have a
job on camera but there but then there's
other moments where it's like you'll see
a photo of yourself and you'll be like
is that what I look like okay or you'll
be like is that what I look like it's
never like that's what I look like it's
either you're in shock or last week in
my denim outfit or you have a deluded
sense of self like and you've been wrong
this whole time so but the thing though
and I know this because I've lived a
long time because I'm old as [__] but I
remember that I did this video with
Cosmo way back in the day and when I
watched it I was like I'm hideous
now I go and I'm like hello cute as a
button yeah so there's a thing where
it's like I have to take a beat because
in my immediate reaction to how I look
is usually terrible I know unless it's
like me in a you know Canadian tuxedo
last night let me say I think if I had
to think about it like really and this
might not be like an exact reflection of
my feelings but it's just a guess I
think my and I'm still like a really
confident person but I think now having
lost so much weight like people when
you're overweight like people just
completely disregard you like you are
not considered in any real way
um so it's easy to like live in your own
world you're really in your own lane
very easy to be confident when you're in
you know a party of one but then when
you lose weight you start being compared
to everyone else like you're actually
considered as a human being and now I
feel like I'm up against other people
and that's harder for me to be the most
confident person in the room wow I feel
totally different yeah let's go I felt
like
I was on an island of one and everybody
could see me that's what it felt like
and that made you feel bad and also like
let's get real like my wife is tall and
thin her sisters are like tall honestly
being in a lesbian relationship like
don't that has to add another element of
like female I want to say almost like
competition ever a million percent you
guys get dressed for the night are you
always like oh [__] she looks better
than me I have psychotic breakdowns over
it I've literally never once thought
about Ben's outfit like in regards to
mine oh my God I remember there was one
time where I was going to the VMAs I was
walking is this white dress white dress
but it was titties saggy just become
friends during the white dress song oh
my God and I have to say your VMA white
red dress Saga has to be one of the
funniest most Taylor Striker things ever
I remember we had just met like maybe
like a year before yeah we weren't like
super tight but we had met a bunch of
times like I really liked you and I
followed you on Instagram and I saw she
was getting ready for the VMAs I'm like
oh my God how exciting and I'm like
literally following the stories and she
has two dresses yep she will she wear
the white one or will she wear the red
one she tries both on she does a poll
and it's like so clear that the red
dress is the better option oh my God
so much more flattering you look
snatched it's just a better dress and I
thought I'm like she's just you know
making content because there's no way
she's gonna wear the white one so you
know what's crazy cut two her picture of
her on the carpet white dress I was just
making content knowing I was gonna wear
the white one and then my parents like
did the ultimate sinful thing as parents
you wanted to automatically wear the
white I was into the white one I thought
that the red one was too like I'm going
to the White House Gala well the one not
[__] the white one was too much I'm
going to a gentleman's club but it's the
it wasn't your best look it wasn't no
kidding and then I did this severe Pony
with like this sad little rat tail in
the back it was a disaster but I was
feeling insecure my parents were like
the red one is more flattering which I'm
like you know what that does to me the
word flattering from a parent means you
look thinner yeah you look
flubby schlubby in the other one and I'm
already in the limo I was like you guys
you're so stupid you know a parent
should know once you're off you're off
and you just send them off with
confidence so I had a full meltdown in
the white limo which was like why am I
in a white extremely tacky and uh Tay
was there and I asked hey please don't
wear heels please wear flats because I
already feel insecure and you are
already so much taller than me so you
even taller like a Lumpkin tree trunk
yes I understand and she was like okay
okay and then right before we were
leaving she was like nope and she
grabbed heels and I was like you selfish
piece of [__] I berate her the entire
ride and then she didn't even end up
coming on the red carpet because she was
so battered by you yeah so battered and
abused that's such an interesting
element of being in a relationship it's
really hard honestly I do there are a
lot of things about lesbianism that I
think are envious totally it's like you
have a built-in best friend cycle
sisters like so many things but that is
not one of them it's not something I
envy at all it happened before Jackie's
Wedding too and we all know what
happened to Jack his wedding oh you guys
were like fighting bad outfits you share
clothes threw my Chanel on the ground
and the next day card Lagerfeld died
coincidence I don't think so definitely
not I killed Carl Lagerfeld that's
something you have to live with and Carl
unfortunately
um do you guys share clothes no because
that could be like a fun like no thank
you we used to and I said I can't
anymore I have this amazing of corzara
navy blue jump soon high waisted halter
low low back I'm short so I would like
belted right like it wasn't ideal but
whatever and then one day with tape was
like panicked for a wedding she was like
I need to wear something I was like oh
wear that and when she came out I was
like oh that's how it's supposed to fit
oh that's tough that's tough no so I
said it's far too triggering I'm too
insecure I can't I really I just can't I
can't see you in the clothes that I love
also that no longer fit me well that's
the thing is like I never have to like
you know
size out of clothes which happens to be
all the time and then have Ben wear it
like that would be hard it's really
sometimes it happens with my sisters yes
but sisters is different because like if
your sister looks good and like you're
getting her ready for an event or
something like you really just want her
to look good and yes your feelings don't
matter exactly there was one time that
tay was in can I have this adorable
bikini and like it's very hard for me to
find bathing suits that fit
so well it wasn't fitting and she was in
can for work and she took a picture of
herself in a bikini on the beach which
like first of all is a great job this is
her fault like so it was like thirsty
and also like insensitive not the
Thirsty and
she was wearing my bikini and I was mad
that she took a picture and felt good
about herself yeah because I'm psychotic
yeah but what I made about was like
so you took my bikini without asking me
the very sister of you we fight about
clothes the way sisters do that is like
one of like the great traumas of my
childhood was like taking a shirt from
Jackie oliviera Margot and like seeing
them in school and then being like you
literally like forcing me into the
bathroom being like take it off
what the [__] am I supposed to wear
they're like take it off right now and
like literally like snitching on me I
mean we all did it to each other what
would you do when you had to take it off
I I you wouldn't actually but like there
would be a moment where I'd be like wait
are you really asking me to take my
[__] pants off in school like you
mean my pants right yeah
give me my pants you mean my past oh I
would have made you walk around into
your like saggy granny panty oh my God
and then like sometimes if you got away
with it like if you were I was in Middle
School and like Jackie was in high
school so we were in different buildings
oh she wouldn't see me wearing the shirt
and like I would get home and like run
and race and put her away you would get
away with it and then like a week later
like somebody would put like a mobile
uploads photo of you on Facebook wearing
the shirt and like Jackie be like is
that my shirt and they should always
leave a nasty comment being like my
shirt
social media it's the best way to punish
someone yeah for stealing we can never
get away with that in this day and age
because people like upload Instagram
stories in real time yes it would always
be like a week later somebody would do
like a dump of their mobile uploads
album on Facebook and you would
literally and you would forget because
you got away with it you'd be like Oh
I'm scot-free but then you always forget
about the mobile uploads my sister and I
literally got into the worst fight of
our life over my mom's Uggs I strangled
her and we broke the bathroom door wow
so you know were you guys physical
Fighters as sisters not until this point
I was like oh in my late 20s and she was
in her early 20s it was like not okay
When We Were Young we were very like we
would like our house like it was like a
slap we wouldn't like punch and kick it
was always a slap on the arm or like
wherever we could get them like we used
to call it a frost which I think means
like punch in Yiddish and like we would
be like I'll give you such a frost like
wait who was the most violent Olivia
she was the strongest
Olivia was definitely like the most
tactile oldest and oldest so she kind of
she really was the ruler of us like if
no one else was around like we had to
defer to Olivia like that's just how we
grew up respecting like the eldest right
and she definitely like was on a power
trip because of it and honestly she was
the most
physically strong uh-huh but maybe I
would say like I was the most Reckless
with my slaps like she would Dole them
out like when necessary but if you got a
slap from Olivia like hospital hospital
she was she's a very strong girl and I
was just kind of like nuts and careless
with my thrust yeah chaotic energy
Ginger Spice oh I wanted to kind of like
address some rumors and I'm glad that
you're here because you can um you can
uh speak to them directly okay I've been
seeing some people being like what's
going on with Claudia and Brian I feel
like I actually haven't seen Ryan he was
traveling all summer I spoke to him the
other day but like I literally have not
seen him physically maybe in two months
the internet is so turned and then we um
you went to dinner with Brian yes and I
think people thought like wow the crew
is getting smaller they're leaving
Claudia out and let me just say Claudia
doesn't want to go to I was invited to
the dinner I had I had a family she
bought dinner that night and I could
have yes I could have shot dinners early
I could have then met you guys but I
really wasn't going to meet you guys at
that vegan restaurant like that to me is
just like not worth my time vegan
Michelin star your two least favorite
things on the face of the planet right I
was like no you guys go and then I saw
the stories I'm like no offense like the
food literally looks horrible I would
never I would not have eaten one more
solo food you wouldn't have we talked
about it at dinner is there a Bread
Basket we talked about it dinner yet but
the butter was like sunflower oil oh my
god oh because it's vegan exactly I'm so
glad so now I just want to clear the
Aaron Taylor can I tell us like me and
Brian are good we'd like a two-hour
FaceTime like two nights ago wait you're
gonna die I totally forgot about this I
got a text like I don't know I guess
like two weeks ago at this point from
Jackie shimel and she's like we are in a
fight question mark I would love to know
why and I was like people thought that
you and I on my podcast Taste of Taylor
when we were talking about ozamic weird
I was talking specifically about an
influencer I know that I love uh-huh but
that like talk match [__] about it was
epic and people just immediately I don't
even think Jackie even talks about it
was that big I want to say a few things
one I actually don't even know who
you're talking about I meant to ask you
after we stopped recording but we had
dinner and definitely don't know this
person okay a million percent so one uh
you'll have to tell me that after two I
never for a second thought it was Jackie
shimel I love Jackie I think if anything
if Jackie Shimmel was the type of person
who struggled with her weight which I
just think she's one of those god-given
Queens who doesn't yeah I think she
would be the first person in line for
ozempic oh my God and I haven't heard
her say a single bad word about it one
thing but I think if she was asked about
it and even if she did I honestly
wouldn't care no but even if she was
asked if she was asked about it just
based on what I know about her I think
she would like be all for it I agree
okay so you wanted to clear that up too
well yeah so like but the internet is
crazy the internet loves like
friendships yeah ending no and then like
psychotically obsessed actually like
self-conscious because I'm really not
like a great friend in the sense where
I'm like we're gonna have lunch once a
week and we'll always stay here it does
no it's like there have been months that
go by where I don't physically see you
but we talk all the time and having like
the internet chime in I'm like oh my God
I need to be like a better friend I
literally have didn't see Brian all
summer
summer was crazy no and Brian is like
literally the world summer Ryan said
world's number one traveler we all hung
out July Fourth weekend and then I don't
think I saw any of you physically no
since then except you and I to work yes
of course Brian also doesn't live in the
state anymore literally so if I want to
see him I have to drive 90 minutes you
know what you do a weekend where we go
apple picking well by the way like we
are doing that but you're not here for
um Dean's first birthday
right you're not welcome now the
internet's gonna think I'm not friends
with Dean
you know what they'd be correct no Dean
is my number one Arch ever honestly ever
since Dean like started that stuff with
you on July 4th weekend it's been kind
of different in the friend group keep in
mind everyone Dean is one years old but
he knows what he did he is so so pointed
he's cunning yeah he's kind of
manipulative very hurtful very hurtful
pointed I just wanted to clear that up I
feel good about it and now we can move
on with our lives
um Taylor schucker I have a question for
you yes are you ready I'm ready for the
past five stories that you need to know
today's episode of the toast is brought
to you by the State Farm personal price
plan the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create a plan that gives you
options so you get an affordable price
and it comes with a lot of benefits like
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this what are your
music playlists podcast feeds and social
media Scrolls all have in common well
spoiler alert they are a reflection of
you we all know my social media is full
of girlies on their ozympic Journey the
Roman Empire
etc etc and Jackie you know she doesn't
even have Tick Tock so we're so
different even though we're so similar
because so personal you know State Farm
gets that that's what the State Farm
personal price plan is all about that's
what it has in common it gives you
options to help you personalize your
coverage so that you can protect what
you care about most at an affordable
price just for you you're also going to
see more of yourself in everything you
love and that includes your insurance so
it's so specific it's so personal you
know what do you have a home you have a
trailer you have a RV you have a bike
you have a motorcycle are you a renter
like so many things State Farm's got you
covered like a good neighbor State Farm
is there there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state option selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
again go to call or go to statefarm.com
today to create your State Farm personal
price plan prices do vary by state
option selected by customer availability
and eligibility may vary today's episode
is also brought to you by Quince even
though my closet was overflowing with
clothes I felt like I had never had
anything to wear then I found Quince and
I've finally given my closet the upgrade
that we both desperately needed I built
out a capsule wardrobe with iconic
pieces that can be styled for any
occasion I have to say the pieces I've
gotten from Quinn's have completely
changed my wardrobe I learned on Tick
Tock about like a capsule wardrobe where
every piece you have can be worn
multiple ways you invest Justin really
good things as opposed to like you know
a bunch of
like uh you spend uh like a lot of money
on a ton of clothes that are like cheap
you invest in good pieces and it will
transform your wardrobe because you can
wear them so many different ways and
Quince is perfect for that they create
Timeless Classics that will never go out
of style you'll have them in your closet
forever and that makes putting together
an outfit way easier Quinn says all the
capsule wardrobe must-haves like 100
Mongolian cashmere sweaters from 50
suede in leather jackets and silk
blouses and dresses and the best part is
that all Quince items are priced 50 to
80 percent less than similar Brands
because they partner with top factories
they can cut out the cost of the
middleman and pass the savings onto us
and Quince only works with factories
that use safe ethical and responsible
manufacturing practices and premium
fabrics and finishes which we love I
also love the pieces that I've gotten
from there I have this amazing cashmere
sweater that I have worn so many
different times but like you wouldn't
notice because I style it differently
every time I also got a great pair of
black trousers that I haven't been able
to wear yet because they're more like
fall I'm gonna start wearing them soon
on the toast and I just feel like
they're going to be my go-to pant for
the season and I'm really excited about
it so take the drama out of planning an
app outfit and upgrade your closet with
Quinn's today go to quince.com toast for
free shipping on your order and 365 day
returns that's
quinc.com toast and get free shipping
and 360 and 365 day returns that's
quince.com toast all right first one I'm
excited to talk about this because I saw
it a few days ago and I didn't choose it
because it seemed so silly to me but now
there's much more to understand okay so
I had seen this headline that Whoopi
Goldberg has been defending Hassan Minaj
and his right to embellish stand-up
stories she said why would Comics tell
exactly what happened it's not that
interesting and that's a headline that I
saw and I completely agreed yes I was
like oh I guess it's come out that like
Hassan has been like embellishing
details of certain stories he tells on
stage and I can't even believe that this
is like a controversy because first of
all same like everyone does that of
course it's you know just a Comics tell
from their own lives and these stories
that are really crazy but when you when
it comes time to making jokes like you
embellish like small details because
people said just to make it funnier for
the audience the ends of course although
I will say my set for stasi's tour was a
hundred percent based in truth in truth
like and that's it's on I honestly
sometimes should just be like yeah I
made it up to my mom to make her feel
better of course but I didn't of course
I did not so I didn't even think the
story was really worth discussing but
then I actually saw a video that
explained the entire Saga and it's a
little bit deeper than Whoopi saying oh
we all Comics embellish okay so there
were a few incidents that Hassan has
become Under Fire for and if you're not
familiar with us seminar she's a huge
fan of comedian he has Netflix specials
he has uh he's the replacement for uh
Trevor Noah on The Daily Show he's like
major Okay so
what he's being accused of is like a
little deeper than just you know I'm
embellishing yeah so there are a few
stories that have you know that he told
on stage that have come out as not being
true and the stories that he is telling
are incidents where he experienced
racism which I think people are a little
um
kerfuffled by because there's really no
need to embellish racism right it's a
real thing right um and so the story
that I think started this whole Saga was
a story he told about when he went to
prom with a girl at the kind of you know
pre-prom where everybody takes pictures
and gives corsages right the girl
wouldn't give him the corsage and gave
it to another guy um because Hassan
Minaj is brown and that's a crazy you
know disgusting story yeah disgusting
and you know people found out who the
girl was that's kind of easy to like
track where prom date was found out who
it was tracked her down terrific story
horrific we're gonna figure out who this
[__] is they sent her threats
like the whole thing and it actually
turns out that that girl never went to
prom with Hassan Minaj he had asked her
like weeks prior she said no I think
maybe she had a date with someone else
and she never went to prom with him
so this is where it's like kind of you
know getting past embellishing and just
like a little a little bit of a danger
zone straight up lie then there's
another story he told about receiving an
envelope with Anthrax [__] and that is
true he did receive an envelope with
Anthrax and he goes on to tell the story
how he opened it in front of his family
and his baby had to go to the hospital
which is insane that's horrific then as
it turns out he did receive an envelope
with Anthrax but he did not open it no
one in his family had to go to the
hospital and the hospital story with his
baby was embellished as well okay now
here's my question because he's a
comedian yeah so it's like okay so if
you're like embellishing okay fine fine
so I tell a story a story about a
strap-on and then I look like Donald
Trump because I was like orange I was
slightly orange I wasn't Donald Trump
orange that that's an exaggeration
that's an exaggeration and the perfect
example of like what a comedian would
just say you you can do you punch it up
it's kind of just a little bit more
funny so what's so interesting is the
way people found out that these stories
weren't true was he literally sat down
with the New Yorker and admitted that
several stories he told in stand-up
routines over the years were embellished
okay one such story involved an anthrax
scare that his family faced in his 2022
Netflix comedy special okay he said that
his daughter came into direct contact
with the white powder and had to go to
the hospital to make sure it wasn't
Anthrax the comedian admitted that that
part of the story was not true although
he did have an anthrax scare that his
daughter was present in the room for
now here's the thing now like I haven't
listened to a special so I I don't have
all the information but like how is
anthrax and a child coming into contact
with it funny I know you know it's like
I know if you're embellishing for comedy
fine but it sounds like he's just
telling a story it that doesn't sound
like it's gonna punch up the punch line
right and so it's almost like it's a
downer yeah no and then when it when you
admit that it's not true it's just like
it just delegitimizes so like it's just
why would you do that and I saw a great
video recapping it and this is how the
video that I had saw that
that I was like oh this is much more
than just embellishment was from KFC
who's a Barstool guy he he said you know
of course all comedians embellish it's
part of the art form it's really not a
big deal but that's to make people laugh
right and so much of Hassan menage's
comedy is to make people think okay and
when you're gonna lie exactly it it's
fraudulent lying about a funny story
embellishing it feels like that fits
into the rules lying about trauma is
kind of a big No-No I know and it's
actually happening right now I know you
don't watch but I'm Roni oh like they're
like they are like
it's like the trauma Olympics oh my God
so infuriating that's the culture we
live in it's like who could be the
biggest victim like it's it's like it's
a competition it's so annoying and thank
God for our girl Uber because she's like
so they're fighting over I had zero
dollars my bank account well I had 20.
and Uber's like zero twenty it's bad no
matter how you slice it or dices voice
of reason thank you but like it really
is like I'm watching it in real time
happen and like shout out to watch her
crapins I love them and I listen a lot
to them so I'm like regurgitating their
opinions credits too but like they're
like so frustrated with like you guys
like let people share their stories but
like there is this fight with this one
girl jessalyn it's like she's lying
about her trauma and I actually don't
think she is I think that there's trauma
they're they're doing this like I'm the
poor I was the poorest right meanwhile
they're all Now Rich right so like it
doesn't matter right but um this one
side is obsessed with the fact that she
was poor and I it was a struggle it was
trauma yeah and she's proud but like
they want jessal to tell her story and
she's like oh yeah I struggled it's not
the same struggle as Psy but everybody's
cuts hurt it's just it's crazy but the
point is that people get really mad when
they think you're lying about trauma for
sure no you are aunt and it just is it
invalidates your your whole message yes
so here's what Whoopi Goldberg had said
if you're gonna hold a comic to the
point where you're gonna check up on
stories you have to understand a lot of
it is the exact is not the exact same
thing that happened because why would we
tell exactly what happened it ain't that
interesting there's information that we
will give you as Comics that will have
grains of truth but don't take it to the
bank that's our job a seed of Truth
sometimes truth and sometimes total BS
and while I agree with that I don't
think it applies here yeah I agree it's
you know Hassan Monash has gotten so
popular for his kind of you know not
polarizing but um thought-provoking
comedy and it's comedy that's really
it's it's of course supposed to make you
giggle but it's really supposed to you
know help you you know uh alter your
your view of the world like it's more
serious than that it's not like dumb
penis jokes right it's it's more mature
than that so I do think there's a higher
bar and I don't know it's really weird
yeah I don't think it'll affect him
it'll just be one of those things like
on his resume but I do think it's really
[__] weird I think it's kind of yeah
it's not a good look yeah and I
understand like the ideology of
comedians supporting this idea because
it's like well I'm not gonna be
hypocrite and dragon for it but like
this is a specific circumstance I agree
and I I think it's wrong I do I do too
um okay next story Britney Spears's
handlers are keeping her from a 60
Minutes promo after her wild Instagram
posts so her upcoming tell-all will just
have to speak for itself because we hear
that every TV Outlet including cbs's
esteemed 60 Minutes is gunning for an
interview with the pop star ahead of the
release of her highly anticipated Memoir
the woman in me
sources tell page six her team does not
feel that she's ready to do a sit-down
interview One Source pointed to Spears's
eccentric Instagram post as one of the
reasons her team is shutting down any
interviews but another source close to
the singer insists that the decision is
solely resting with Spears
she's a free woman she'll decide it's
her choice they said she had offers and
she doesn't want to do anything she of
course has had a complicated
relationship with the media ever since
she hit the scene as a teen in 1998.
yeah she's been straight up traumatized
by I mean reputable news anchors we've
seen all those Diane Sawyer interviews
right like these are people that like We
As Americans trust dead I think we can
use past tense here yes but like when
Diane Sawyer is coming for you like you
have America on your side and so times
are different but I understand why she's
like living in a time capsule yeah and I
do want to say like I don't think 60
Minutes would be a good platform for
Brittany it's so serious and like
political and I don't think people like
turn to it for pop culture yeah I think
there are so many different Platforms in
this day and age that are so the
opposite of those Diane Sawyer days yes
I think of course like a podcast I could
see her doing like a Jay Shetty yep
um somebody who's gentle and empathetic
yes I could see her really doing a
podcast because there's really no
limitations and they could add it in the
way that she wants to do the toes I mean
of course she's always welcome I can
also see her doing something you know
very Megan and Harry did with Oprah yes
where Oprah's very like a safe space
although didn't over oh there's this new
documentary I don't know if it's on
Netflix but I watched last night it's
about um the supermodels of the 90s like
yeah we talked about it yesterday and
one of them I I have not gotten that far
but uh brought up Oprah kind of like
dragging Oprah yes uh Cindy uh Cindy
Crawford said that Oprah made her get up
on her show and like show off her body
to everyone when she was 16 in a way
that felt very bizarre
Dean okay interesting Cindy's also an
interesting one herself how so
um she uh takes herself a little bit too
seriously okay you know okay so and this
is something that I think Meghan
markle's guilty of too and I love Meghan
Markle but I think that like sometimes
like people you're off put by someone's
personality like Tay was like losing her
mind over Cindy Crawford like not in a
good way like she was like she's driving
me nuts in the documentary yes and I was
like it's not that Cindy's not smart
because she is smart but she goes out of
way to be like I'm smart I'm smart I'm
smart yeah so then you're like hyper
analyzing everything she says but also I
think that Cindy thinks she's like
really really funny you know it's it's
oh that's tough you can't be everything
you can't be beautiful rich and funny
pgs pretty girl syndrome yeah and not
all pretty girls like suffer from this
but Cindy Crawford maybe does and it's
just like I'm so funny I'm so smart and
it's like just be you and we'll love you
and we'll we'll find you funny and smart
yes but when you have to tell this it's
very annoying and so I think that like I
think Meghan Markle people like don't
like occur and it's like no that's
because you don't like her sense of
humor she
thinks funny she's trying to be funny
she wants to you know put out to the
world that she's this really kind of
sophisticated person and she is and we
could glean that but you don't have to
sit down and be like we don't watch TV
like shut up like people hate when
people say that like exactly watch his
TV and it makes us feel bad like we're
stupid yeah yes
um so I don't think like her not going
on 60 Minutes is a big deal but I do
think the book comes out next month I do
not think people get a sit-down
interview she's not mentally fit for it
and that's the reason and that's fine
first of all I don't think it will even
affect Book Sales whatsoever just
because I mean it actually might even
help them yeah more mystery
um but I am worried about Brittany who
isn't like I just you know how about
this let her do the book
whatever the [__] she wants to do I
think she should do the thing is I think
she needs money now like I do think for
real she hasn't been working for a while
she had an enormous amount of money that
was dwindled by her conservatorship yes
by the time she got out of the
conservatorship I think there was a good
chunk of money but not enough to never
work again and to live this very very
premium lifestyle with this big wedding
and every week taking a private jet to
Maui with Sam like rights I don't think
there is and she's done two songs
Tiny Dancer was fine but it's a collab
with Elton John like it's not gonna make
you money for life I feel they're too so
oh and will I am yeah that flopped I
feel like uh music Alone doesn't really
make money anymore no it doesn't that's
why every artist tours right merch
podcast like everybody does a million
things to support the music right so I
don't know she got what 15 million for
the book yes you have to outsell that
before you make any more money off this
is something that nobody knows yeah so
you get an advance for a book so hers is
15 million dollars they'll give you uh
they split into three chunks so that's
five million upon signing yep five
million upon handing in your manuscript
and then five million um upon publishing
then in the months that follow the
publisher has to earn back 15 million
dollars in book sales before you make
another Cent it's crazy now I do think
her book will out earn 15 million
dollars don't hit it do you owe no
retroactively okay it's just like a bad
investment for the publisher I'll
probably not give you a second book deal
okay yeah 15 million dollars is a lot
but we always talk about this we love to
count people's money we do and stress
ourselves out for Britney Spears 15
million dollars is not a lot of it's not
a lot considering just the life she
leads the big house right the Jets the
Glam the security the security that's
the real and the lawyers managers and
publicists who are on your payroll oh
for you get that I mean managers right
there 30 is gone right so let's say she
gets the 15 million dollars really after
taxes at seven million dollars but you
pay everybody on the 15th no you pay
every you it's tax deductible
commissions
oh what yeah your commissions are tax
deductible
so she's 10 to an agent 10 to a manager
okay five percent to a business manager
that's 25 what's 25 of 7 million girl
you asking me I didn't even know that I
could deduce the taxes 25 of 7 million
is
I want to say 1.5 million dollars is
that right
I feel like it's not one point
so seven minus 1.75 is 5.25 your rain
man so of her 15 million dollars she
keeps 5.25
my brain is exploding and melting out my
ears right now I don't I haven't heard
anything you said in the last 30 seconds
okay so she got a 15 million dollar book
Advance yes what she will actually go
home with is 5.25 that's not that's
nothing nothing chump change so
she better out earn that book advance so
she can make more money yeah she needs
to actually go on 60 Minutes she needs
to do some press she does I feel like
they'll be giving excerpts to like book
review and so in the weeks leading up
we'll see like bombshell from Brittany
so by the time it comes out there's a
lot of hype but you gotta do the rounds
but she's she's really not mentally fit
for it yeah I agree today's episode is
brought to you by game time buying
tickets for your favorite events should
not be stressful game time is the best
and easy way to buy tickets for all the
sports music comedy and theater near you
with killer deals on last minute tickets
and their best price guaranteed you can
stop stressing over the tickets and
start getting hyped for the fun you'll
have I feel like we live in a day and
age we're like getting tickets for stuff
has become a torturous Excursion and
it's pricey and it's not fun and you
never get the seats you want and game
time is here to just like alleviate some
of the pressure so if they are the place
for last minute ticket deals forget
planning months in advance like I'm just
never gonna be that type of girl I'm
gonna decide the day of if I want to go
to something and game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and more the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price and if you find tickets in
the same section and row for Less game
time will credit you 110 of the
difference it's the fastest growing
ticketing app in the country for a
reason get images of your seats before
you buy so you know exactly what to
expect when you arrive buy tickets a
matter of seconds it's literally two
Taps and you're all set and then tickets
are sent directly to your phone so you
never have to dig through your email
like waiting in line holding everybody
up you're like wait sorry I can't find
my ticket it's like game time makes it
easy so you don't look like a dope in
front of everyone snag the tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem code toast
for 20 off download the game time app
today it's last minute tickets it's
lowest price it's guaranteed
thank you game time for sponsoring
today's episode today's episode is also
brought to you by Lululemon specifically
Lululemon leggings they have the best
leggings and thankfully we are entering
leggings season we're covering up our
legs we don't have to shave them anymore
so we're heading to Lululemon to find
the perfect pair of leggings to cover
our prickly little legs with so there's
so many different options when it comes
to leggings that's what I love about
Lululemon they have a ton of different
pairs like based on what you're looking
for but here are some of my favorites
the fast and free leggings which are
powered by new looks they provide a
waitlist on body sensation and
incredible coverage and they're designed
for those looking for a legging that
gives them the complete freedom from
distractions while running jogging also
the Wonder train leggings they're
designed with one of one of Lululemon's
most Innovative Fabrics which is
everlocks the everlux fabric is Lou
lemon's fastest drying fabric the Wonder
train legging allow you to work hard and
feel dry so you can effortlessly
transition from sweat to street they're
great for activities like spin
also the Align leggings they're powered
by the nulu fabric which is designed for
the person who wants a lightweight low
compression yoga solution that is also
versatile enough for casual wear it
gives the wearer a next to nothing body
sensation and it gives the wearer the
full freedom of movement so it doesn't
restrict or compress the wearer in any
way it's great for low intensity
workouts like yoga or just for casual
wear like if you're the type of girly
who loves to wear workout clothing
without working out like that's a valid
way of living your life and don't let
anyone tell you any different
we've got you covered at Lululemon like
from high intensity to low intensity
you're just sitting on your couch and
you want comfy pants Lou Lemon has you
covered so get into the Lululemon
leggings like they are the leggings of
the moment she is the moment you can get
into them at lululemon.com of course you
can shop in store but check out all the
different type of types of leggings they
have and be prepared for fall at
lululemon.com today's episode is brought
to you by Court furniture rental life is
always changing your furniture should be
able to change with it and with cord
furniture rental you can get the
furniture and services you need to help
make everyday life transitions as
seamless as possible so whether you're
doing a short-term distance move you're
relocating you're starting a new chapter
or you simply just don't want to be tied
down to owning Furniture court is the
solution for you you'll simply pick the
furniture you want then their expert
team will deliver it and set it up the
furniture will be there when you need it
and gone when you don't get furniture on
your own terms with the court furniture
rental visit court.com podcast to learn
more and find the furniture package that
fits your life court is spelled c-o-r-t
you press play whenever you want with
the furniture rental from Court you rent
Furniture when you need it and turn it
when you don't so there's a million
reasons like I can't believe there
aren't you know like more like furniture
rental has become this like obscure
thing it's so simple there's a million
reasons why you might not want to Own
Furniture whether you live like a very
you know Wanderlust kind of life you
travel a lot you're doing a short-term
stay somewhere but also if you're not
and you just don't want to Own Furniture
Trends Trends and Furniture change so
frequently like to not own it is such a
luxury and court is there for you so
make sure you go to court
c-o-r-t.com slash podcast
c-o-r-t.com to learn more and find the
furniture package that will fit your
needs that's
courtcort.com podcast for furniture
rental which is just a much more
sustainable way of living
and you know you don't have to lift a
finger which is just all right by me
court.com slash podcast okay let's see
what my second Britney Spears story
which is so weird that we have two
Britney Spears stories but I was shocked
I didn't
um hear about this and I think this is
in an effort to promote the book in kind
of different and non-traditional ways
because homegirl can't sit down for an
interview right her 2002 movie
Crossroads is set for an October
re-release in theaters oh my God which
is amazing so Britney Spears's 2002 film
Crossroads is returning to the big
screen the teenage dramedy featuring the
princess of pop in her first feature
role will be released in cinemas all
around the world on October 23rd and
25th timed for the publication of her
new tell-all Memoir the woman in me so
Travel Guard releasing which is the Sony
Music Entertainment and RCA records
announced the global Fan event on
Thursday it does mean that crossroads
will go up against Taylor Swift the
era's tour although Taylor Swift's new
concert pick will have a much bigger
footprint right but also hers opens on
October 13th and they're going 10 days
later on October 23rd so I think she's
okay it will be playing in thousands of
theaters across North America the era
store Crossroads is about 875 locations
okay so this is just like a cute new and
different way and I imagine that the the
first feature film is like a big turning
point in your career and in the book I
think she probably talks about it a lot
and the title The Woman in me is of
course from the song I'm not a girl not
yet a woman which was an original song
from the soundtrack Crossroads I'm not a
girl don't tell me what to believe
I'm just trying to find a woman in me
that song was really important to me in
the fourth grade and if you don't know
watch my comedy special disgrace Queen
available for free on Amazon time it was
like an important coming-of-age story
for me yes so I love this movie as much
as I'm not like a Die Hard Britney this
movie raised me like we had it on VHS we
would play it rewind play it rewind like
we were obsessed with this movie it's
the worst movie ever what you heard me
it's the best movie ever and might I say
star-studded Zoe Saldana I know Taryn
Manning eating people's butts yeah she's
lost her mind and wait Kim Cattrall pays
plays Britney Spears's mother who
abandoned her
when he drives to Arizona to meet her
mother spoiler Kim Cattrall wants
something to do with Britney Spears you
know what I feel like maybe I've never
seen it straight through it is let's go
okay I'll go to school for Britney meet
Taylor it is the best movie it's like
one of the greatest movies of all time I
mean I've definitely seen Snippets of it
but maybe not straight through and
through
um well
brighter strike is always on the mind so
like Kim Cattrall will get residuals yes
as will Terence so she can continue
Taryn Manning has lost her mind her butt
munching I don't think so I think she
was just a woman [__] scorned in a
moment
by the man that she was cheating with
what are you talking about Taryn Manning
she was just in her car saying that like
I love him and I eat his butt and his
butt is so delicious I'm talking about
something else she has like gone too bad
making so many Instagram stories that
Danny Masterson was wrongfully convicted
of rape no
like you all think I'm crazy but I'm not
like she's nuts the butt munching is
what started it okay tell me about
munchie sorry okay so she was having an
affair with ma'am apparently she's kind
of like addicted to married men it's
like her friends married okay yes and so
his wife was mad understandably so and
then Taryn was mad at the wife being mad
and so she got in her car and she went
crazy and posted it but she was
basically like you think I'm crazy
you're crazy and then she has a little
like southern lispy thing and then she
was basically like I ate his butt and he
liked it and I'll eat his butt again and
I like it in people's butts and I was
like did you ever did you ever watch
Orange is the New Black
because she's literally turns and turned
into her character pantsatucky method
acting yeah she took method acting a
little too far like pencitucky was that
her name pencil Chucky yup she was like
this you know quirky nutty Prison inmate
meth addict
and honestly she took the role a little
too seriously because she's become I
just like I'm joking about it but like I
actually hope she's okay but like I
really can't get behind you I think
she's okay because her apology sent like
sounded like she was like you all think
I'm on pills but I'm not this is just
someone says someone on pills really I
don't know I imagine if I wasn't on
pills I would tell everyone I'm not on
pills that's true so what would a Pill
Popper say the same yeah
um oh the Danny master and stuff is bad
yeah I know he he's you want to go on
the Side of Innocence no but by the way
so she we reported we talked about
yesterday on the toast that his wife
Bijou Phillips is filing for divorce yes
which we said was like a weird tactic to
like Stand By Your Man in his rape trial
but then
she obviously thought he was innocent
and now he's an innocent man in prison
and you're gonna leave him and somebody
um did point out that there will be
civil suits launched against any
Masterson so maybe it's a financial
maneuver right which is like just even
more like these are disgusting people I
support Bijou in this moment you do I
mean the lesser of two evils yeah but
like she's still standing by her man but
divorcing is at least but she's divorced
it sounds like she's divorcing him on
paper like she'll still go and visit him
with the kids with conjugal visits and
stuff right yeah oh God I can't think of
anything less sexy than prison
like even if literally Jacob Ballard he
wanted to [__] me he's like but we can
only do it when I'm in prison during my
conjugal visit I'd be like well it's
just not gonna happen I mean can you
imagine all of the venereal diseases no
no no
um okay so I love this by the way this
is like actually smart marketing like oh
we have a a our talent can't sit down
for an interview we got to get creative
yes and they're really seeing this movie
is actually brilliant and maybe it'll
open up you know gen Z to a movie
they've never seen and they should see
it's a coming-of-age story and it's
smart Universal message
I love rock and roll so put another
Diamond I love this movie this movie
means a lot to me like for real
okay our next story oh and well I just
switched up our next story because I
forgot that I wanted to talk about when
you brought up Oprah I forgot that Oprah
was asked about ozembic and she had some
hot takes ooh which I find interesting
so Oprah Winfrey says she wrestled with
the thoughts on ozempen she said if I
take the drug that's the easy way out
which is my least favorite thing for
people to say
so Oprah Winfrey is joining the
conversation surrounding using uh the
usage of type 2 diabetes drug ozympic
for weight class the media Mogul 68
recently hosted a panel I'm discussing
the Obesity and weight crisis which
affects 2 billion adults globally she
held the conversation alongside obesity
specialist Dr Fatima Cody Stanford and
Dr Melanie J and a psychologist named
Rachel Goldman Jewish Queen
free who's a board member and
shareholder of Weight Watchers was also
joined by SEMA sistani who's the CEO of
Weight Watchers right and they recently
that's why I want to talk about it
Weight Watchers recently opened up about
yes they started a new Telehealth
treatment option for weight loss drugs
they um it was big news they had bought
like major shares in like a Novo Nordic
so they're they're now in the ozempic
game they're bringing some glue Tides
into the which is very smart because
they've been at like that they have been
the leading sort of they've made it
through diet culture Weight Watchers has
just been like a leading weight loss
resource for many people it's worked for
so many people for 30 years if they want
but also they change up the program and
it [__] me up I'll tell you that much
yes I did not like the new way of doing
things they were like corn a big lump
with knobs they were like zero points
I'm like I will eat 25 years of corn but
it still hasn't working it's done a
really good job of changing with the
times like bringing in Oprah was really
great for them and so now Jake they're
now WWE like they keep up with the times
where I feel like a lot of diets have
been kind of canceled which says lot of
yeah they are they're here to stay and
that is why they're with some good times
because some good times are here to stay
yeah that's the whole thing it's kind of
like a really I think big smart decision
of them but I was curious what Oprah had
to say about it I think that Oprah's
also saying the easy way out because she
has literal Financial stake in people so
not just because why do you need Weight
Watchers when you have Oz I want to say
I think a lot of the headlines did Oprah
dirty here's what she really said okay
okay shouldn't we all just be more
accepting of whatever body you choose to
be in that should be your choice okay
even when I first started hearing about
the weight loss drugs at the same time I
was going through knee surgery and I
felt I've got to do this on my own
because if I take the drug that's the
easy way out she also explained that she
was shamed in the tabloids every week
for about 25 years for not having the
willpower when it comes to her weight
loss journey and then the Obesity
medicine physician Dr Fatima Cody
Stanford said obesity is a chronic
disease and willpower isn't a word that
she uses when it comes to her patients
it's hard to see you ostracized in the
way that you've been because this isn't
about willpower it's not your fault it's
how our bodies regulate weight and each
of us different each of us is unique no
one is superior to another we're just
different in acting on those differences
and treating those differences in the
heterogeneity of the population is how
we're going to actually make changes to
the disease so of course Oprah has been
vocal about her health Journey
um revealing in October 22 that she
recovered from double knee surgery the
year prior she said I had knee surgery
in August and then another in November
when I came home for the first time it
literally could not lift my leg I
couldn't lift my heel off the bed and I
vowed if I was ever able to get up walk
around and move again that I would take
advantage of my movement exercise and
being able to be fully in my body so she
didn't like
she didn't bash I was epic but like she
didn't she wasn't like a voice that we
we could have used her to be like a
voice of reason yes and a lot of people
really respect Oprah I think a lot of
like
people of all sizes she's kind of like a
pillar in the overweight Community but
she's a global pillar and people just
respect the [__] out of whatever she
says and she shuts people down all the
time and it would have loved her to use
this as an opportunity to shut people
down because she of anyone should know
how like obesity is a lifelong battle
Yeah and I don't know I just feel like
she could have done better it's giving
I'm on ozampic but I don't really want
anyone to know because I have so much
money in Weight Watchers like Weight
Watchers has a lot to gain from
semi-glue tide so if anything Oprah as a
board member should be praising it no
because I literally the other day was
like why am I paying for Weight Watchers
I'm on ozembic it is natural I don't
need it when I go off of ozone picker my
tri zipitide people get very mad at me
about that but like I'll definitely go
back on Weight Watchers just for right
now I don't need it because my willpower
is like a shot ozempic is watching your
weight you don't need to watch
absolutely yeah absolutely so maybe
that's why she's taking the stance she
is I just think there really needs to be
more um critical thinking like nuanced
conversation around ozambic I know every
time it's in the media it's like you
know Jackie goldschneider loves to climb
on this epic
um yeah and of course our headline
recently was like it's she's always
talking about it I starve myself to be
thin but I still wouldn't take ozempic
of course thank you for saying that
you're the exact type of person who
shouldn't take ozone exactly her
experience is totally colored I mean her
opinion is totally colored by her own
experience yeah which is fine but she
just shouldn't like make broad
statements like with you know sweeping
with wide Strokes or whatever they say
because she's so clearly has a trauma
and that affects how she sees these
things but she she just can't even get
into the mindset of someone with the
opposite problem of her she was striving
to be skinny and was doing everything
she can to be skinny and she can't even
grasp the opposite of that people who
literally cannot stop gaining weight no
matter how hard they try nothing works
them she can't even empathize with that
person yeah she can't see any experience
other than her own which is fine so her
to say I would never take ozamic you
shouldn't right you're literally the
exact type of person a doctor would not
recommend it for exactly but stop like
making you know
broad statements about other people like
it just bothers me and so for Oprah I
felt like this could have been such a
fabulous powerful conversation you know
and I feel like oh brought us down she
did let us down she did oh she lets into
Crawford down she let the Chubbies down
she really did I don't know like it
could have been it could have been major
I know we just need we need more people
like doing what we do I feel like in I
think it's gonna be like two years but
definitely five like people are gonna be
looking back on the times that they were
criticizing ozone but like what the [__]
was I doing no there's just like such a
love look at the last laugh there's such
a lot a lack of logic because people are
like well we don't know what it's gonna
what it's gonna do to people like
actually we do it the drug has been it's
not new it's been around for 15 years
yeah diabetes have been taking it yes
four years that's why so many doctors
feel so comfortable prescribing it to
patients because it has a track record
they're like this newfangled drug yeah
it's not new girl yeah it's been around
for a really long time and when you say
that you're like basically screaming
like I don't know any doctors and it's
like I feel bad for you right because
I'm surrounded by doctors me too I'm
just like and it's like amazing I'm
basically a doctor I pretty much am a
doctor I would say
yes have you been following the story of
the plane video that went viral where
this Instagram model was like I'm an
Instagram famous person like she was
being crazy okay people are just like
obsessed with it now they found out who
she was she is Instagram famous she was
getting booted off a plane and
everyone's Instagram famous she had 900
000 followers I think she has more now
girl she really went viral she had she's
wearing like the skin tight gray
bodysuit I was like oh my God on a plane
yeah like a onesie like a unitard
unitard she had an amazing body how'd
she pee it was
I mean light gray she is no okay she is
braver than any woman I've ever met
so
people figured out who she was and now
she's speaking out it appeared in the
video she was getting booted off the
plane and everybody was like Boo get off
get off and she's oh [__] you [__] you
I'm Instagram famous like I like her
energy so they found out I know that's
literally me
um so the Instagram model uh in plain
meltdown says that she left to avoid
knocking her seat mate the [__] out she
claims she wasn't kicked off the plane
she left because her seat mate was
annoying her so self-proclaimed
Instagram famous model Morgan Osman
denies that she was actually booted from
the American Airlines flight in her now
viral video moment insisted that she
left to avoid knocking her annoying seat
mate the [__] out now the reason why I
chose this story is because they found
out who she was and the reason is so
clear like this this next sentence will
clear everything up for you the Bad
Girls Club alumna told TMZ on Wednesday
that while she didn't mind being called
the latest crazy plain lady the backlash
to her video was unfair because it
didn't show that she had been provoked
before storming off the jet okay she
said I was just living life it was the
lady next to me she came in so hot and
she said this is what she said of the
woman who kept telling her to get up she
had neon blue hair she was very special
I don't know who you think you are this
is what she said to her seatmate I don't
know who you think you are talking to me
but it won't be me question yeah first
class or economy coach and she sat down
next to me she got on FaceTime she's
making fun of me on FaceTime the
influencer claimed so I said to myself
Morgan this is not the flight for you
you already missed one flight just get
off the flight because I'm Gonna Knock
her the [__] out
it was only when she decided to remove
herself and wave down the stewardess
that people then whipped out her cat
their camera okay the now viral video
shows Osman clad in a curve hugging gray
bodysuit bickering with other passengers
and telling one of them feel me I'm
Instagram famous you [__] bum I love
her no I'm kind of obsessed she told TMZ
I still think they're a bunch of [__]
bums they are bums I mean listen you
can't dress like that and act crazy you
have to wear like sweatpants and hide
and with a hoodie if you're gonna like
lose your [__] [__] do you drink on
planes
um you know what I used to and I kind of
stopped this last tour so now it's kind
of re-regulated me but I used to get I
mean [__] hammered on flights like I
have never ever once had an altercation
on a flight like I avoid
conflict I avoid any sort of fighting
um but I imagine if I was the type of
person who had cocktails on a plane like
I would look for a fight you definitely
would so I I don't know like how people
drink on flights for a multitude of
reasons like don't you get a headache no
but but you do get way more [__] up
from last when you're because altitude I
have been drunk on a plane once and and
I was going to Mexico I was with Brian
Kelly okay we had a layover in Houston
so we were in the lounge and you know I
flew with Brian so they like picked us
up they drove us they gave us this fancy
Lounge we had margaritas and we saw two
other people on the flight that we knew
so they joined us in the lounge we're
partying we're drinking they're on our
flight to Mexico it's first class so
there's like eight seats I know four of
the people right we're all listening to
the same pair of headphones listening to
music like getting wasted and we would
definitely like drunk enough to be like
a problem but we were just having fun
like we were not disrupted right and the
flight attendant couldn't have been
nicer he was like I just want to make
sure like you guys aren't driving we're
like no we have a car picking us up and
he was like oh my God the most passive
aggressive of way of saying you guys are
drunk no but he was lit like he was
honestly I believe he was like a gay man
and I was it was I was with three gay
men right so he was very like simpatico
energy yes and then I looked back like
the next day I was like damn I was
really drunk on that plane and I've
never been drunk I'm like oh God like
what was I capable of but I've never
been drugged on a plane before you're
capable of screaming at everybody yeah
you are internet famous no honestly it
was nice to know like if I'm like Drunk
on a Plane I'm just a good time I am
always ready for a fight in a plane I'm
I want to fight you about my overhead
space yeah
I will fight you about like like just a
million different things I am I'm an
open nerve so I am very much in support
of this bad girl the people in first
class are really [__] annoying about
um the overhead bin space sure once
you're all there can I have a little
square no I'm not talking about that
once they're all there for sure yeah but
people in first class like love to come
to first class and super late yes and
just expect that there's space for them
and there are other people in first
class so I like to come on late your
fellow first class cabin passengers have
taken the space yes and to throw a hissy
fit like well I'm In First Class I
deserve to have space so it's like you
got to get here on time girlfriend they
have like a complex when I the very
infrequent times that I'm first class
the way I look everybody that comes oh
down the aisle up and down I'm the
biggest [__] [__] when I'm first
class yeah you know I'm like modest
about it I just keep my head down I just
look at everybody's outfits no it's so
funny like when you're not in first
class you look at the first class
passengers with such contempt with such
like jealousy and hatred totally and
when you are in first class like and you
see people walking by like you actually
like you know what that's like like you
feel like
like you want to tell me I don't always
fly first class not me momentarily I'm
like I am better than everyone oh so you
take you don't take the higher up no I
take the lowest of the low that's so you
and I know it I absolutely one thing
about you like you're gonna be
consistent
consistently toxic
name of your first Memoir consistently
toxic
the consistently toxic lesbian
you need to have the consistently toxic
lesbian who took ozone picks but it's
actually tricepatibe it needs to just be
like fully encapsulate your journey who
fraudulently laughs at Claudia ashrae
yes there you go colon the Taylor
strucker story
was that a real effort that's a real one
you make me cackle I'm a cackling hag
when I'm with you I don't know if I
believe you Claude Ed stop no kidding
you give me such a heart attack I love
you so dearly I mean the feeling is
quite Mutual this I think like for me I
feel good like I made up for my poor
performance on last episode you were
fabulous last time I was just like quiet
and like clenching my butt cheeks
together everyone needs to know that
Claudia was spiraling so hard she sent
me baked by Melissa cup I feel like so
bad I was like I made her come all the
way and like I just Claudia get up
literally I had the cupcakes I
absolutely did every single one no
yes now your wife's gonna get fat she
was like I cannot believe Claudia sent
these I know I'm such a toxic ozone big
friend
well I love you if you guys enjoyed what
you heard here today Taylor schrecker is
a fabulous podcast so she has two shows
her free podcast is called Taste of
Taylor they just released a new episode
today so they release episodes every
Thursday I'm on a little on it a lot yes
his great guess it's super funny it's
pop culture it's lifestyle it's comedy
it's everything it's Taste of Taylor
available wherever you get your podcast
and she also does a Daily Show much like
the toast it's on patreon it's 6.95 for
the entire month she does an hour every
single day with her her co-hosts her
friends pop culture it's good stuff she
talks a lot about ozembic so if you're
fatigued of that just be warned and it's
fabulous it's patreon.com
thetaylorstrucker show don't miss it
it's fabulous support our girl who
supports the toast and our times of need
oh so thank you Taylor for being here I
love you I love you and thank you guys
so much for listening to the testimony
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories you need to know everybody
the Friday New tubes if you're watching
us on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe to give this video a thumbs up
we're also available Spotify to Sister
public radio I already cast box all the
places my business podcast
have a great day bye bye